he says it's time for real change and
this lot agree but are the public ready
Jeremy Corbyn armed with the most
expensive election offer in political
history this manifesto is and I'm proud
of it
the most radical and ambitious plan to
transform our country for decades big
taxes for big business and big earners
in order to fund a 5% pay rise for all
public sector workers money for the NHS
for social care for hospitals for
schools when Labour wins the nurse wins
the student wins the pensioner wins the
tenant wins the young couple wins we all
win a manifesto of hope for the many but
putting fear into the hearts of the few
we will go after the tax dodgers the bad
bosses the big polluters that's why they
throw everything they've got at us
because they're scared of real change
because they aren't on your side this
election is happening because of brexit
for many voters someone who wants to be
Prime Minister but won't answer whether
they bat leave or remain is perhaps a
bit of a joke can you give us a straight
answer today is it leave or remain the
tenor of the questions that you gave me
is that we've got to carry on forever
being dividing the tenor of what I'm
saying is let's get together on this the
British people have the final say our
government will carry it out whatever
the result of that vote is they believe
but the polls suggests the public have
their doubts the policies are really
popular what about Jeremy is he the
bloke whole neighbor
clear leadership on inequality on public
services not clearly to ship all grexit
wrong on that one but I pick a country
begging to be brought back together
again
they want to Unitas comes up as more of
a problem Jeremy Corbyn or you're
confusing brexit policy what comes up on
the door set the absolute crisis in the
NHS is going to fight the people is
gonna is going to recruit more doctors
recruit my nurses and fight for the
policy don't say they think he's a poor
leader I've never had that on the dorset
Jeremy Corbyn has left this law to take
his radical program for government
around the country he wants his
manifesto of hope as he puts it to
inject some much-needed momentum into
the labour campaign because with just
three weeks to go labour really needs to
start closing the gap with the Tories
but two hard dolls remain one is his
torturous position on brexit and the
other is Jeremy Corbyn himself his enemy
is quick to criticize what we want to
know is what is his plan to deliver
brexit and what's the deal he wants to
do and which side would he vote on that
deal then we still don't know until we
have answers to those questions until we
get brexit done
none of this carries any economic
credibility whatever flavor hang in
there hopes on voters liking these
pledges but this manifesto is even more
radical than the one that didn't get
them over the line in 2017 the gamble is
that two years on people now want
something more radical not conservative
but the biggest question of all is do
they want him Beth Rick B Sky News
Birmingham